you know as John mentioned this is
extremely labor intensive and expensive
and we all know that that one of the
problems with films today's they're not
expensive enough so back to see lots
more now the first thing I add here is
well I'm not a lawyer and to quote a
line from The Simpsons nor do I play one
on TV but you know it seems like
ownership of performance is a really big
question here and and I think it's
something that probably won't be
answered by us be answered by some
committee and sag to see what you do it
but I just want to get anybody's you
know you know you know thoughts on that
like you know if you because when if
somebody owns this and I know from the
film I just finished
you know we recreated Holograms of
Sinatra Elvis and Marilyn Monroe and we
had to get approval and payment to the
estates of all of those those those
actors so I just like to get anybody's
thought on that like ownership you know
if there is any I mean we're all not
lawyers were creative people but any
comments oh well you know some of this
is a bit of a new area you know a lot of
the examples you mentioned there was no
foreseeing this technology back in the
day so you know there's nothing on
record from from any of those performers
but their wishes about the use of their
likeness and you know that's that that
is I think a serious issue I think we've
done that the right thing of talking to
their estates and their heirs about it
but in the end we still don't know how
they whether they would have agreed to
it it seems like they need to do
something that's similar to like
residuals for for actors when they have
been there when their their face has
seen someplace they could you know their
face is seen it's their property and I
would think so you know but the next
question I had here is just okay yeah
one other comment especially with
there's appearance
there's performance and even the stuff
that I just showed you that sort of
scary stuff up there when you watch the
people I'm controlling
it's my performance and I can change the
appearance or we're getting the ability
to change the appearance but the
performance is extraordinarily hard to
change that that's something that we
don't have technology to take away so if
I control your face you can tell it's me
controlling your face or CeCe's
controlling me you will see Cece coming
through that yeah it's like Karen
carnival and Maurice the a exactly
exactly but on the flip side of that
though when I am like right now as I'm
here or as I am doing an interview like
that that's that's caring like go to
data or whatever but when I go into
Maurice my energy trends transforms
completely that's part of the thing so
that's something that you wouldn't
recognize as Karen Carnival me as
Maurice my boo or whatever whatever
whatever I do with my voice whatever so
I don't know but what that does because
that's a that is a total energy change
for me as an actor it's the thing that
I'm that's what I do is it transform
whether I've got makeup or digital or
what it doesn't really it doesn't matter
what it is so I don't know how one how
one tracks that but anyway just one of
them piggyback on that because one of
the things that Jim Cameron said was it
seemed as if every seven or eight weeks
he goes this what we did here it's
obsolete there's something new that's
come down the pike it's completely
different gonna make it faster more and
we were constantly changing and moving
things around to accommodate new
technology and that's within a two
three-month span so at the speed that
it's going how are these performers
going to catch up by the time they
figure out the first thing the 15th
thing is already well speaking from
somebody else to figure out all this
stuff and be fast on the day I think
that
you know John can certainly and and
every all the other visual effects of
risers here is like we stay up late to
try to just you show up and do the magic
that you do because it comes from
somewhere deep inside you right and
that's what makes the truth the
performance which sort of leads me into
this next question and doing the show
I've heard a lot from directors and
actors about finding the truth you know
like like it's like if if truth is
essential to make a formants performance
believable in and and and pointed to
people you know how how does that how
does that in happy because truth is the
animation the animators have to come in
and and help that right but not not blow
it you know what I mean it's like it's
like it's like a core of a performance
that you come over and then you change
and I know our movie we did it because
then he said well I like it up to here
but I want it to go to here right so we
had to change and I'd love to get your
comments on that yeah I mean for
animators were kind of in a weird spot
right so we're between the actor and the
director and sometimes will completely
manipulate performance to where it's not
even the same thing the actor did but
it's the essence of what the director
was going for so you're still trying to
get the same pepper for performance but
maybe they're turning left instead of
turning right other times we'll take a
couple different performances by that
actor and marry them into one which
isn't the preferable way to do it
honestly it doesn't it always feels a
little weird depending on how you cut it
together but essentially it's like an
editor cutting together a performance so
it's not unheard of in filmmaking it's
just done in a very different way where
the animator is control and so sometimes
animators are bringing their own
performance to it they'll go shoot their
own reference and they'll bring that to
it but it's all in service of the
character and in service of the director
so you know depending on what the
character is sometimes they're fully
keyframed because they're in a animal so
you had tiger on a boat or it's tweaking
eye twitches to be at the right beat you
know
so it's it we kind of take on
responsibilities on both sides but where
that ownership of the performance lies
is often often kind of a mix at the
group now sometimes the more human they
are the more directed is from the actor
to final thing but depending on how
creature they get sometimes they're not
sometimes they have many more arms or
legs and then animator is very involved
in the performance and there's a lot of
different ways to make a movie there's a
lot of different processes and you know
there's you can swing all the way to you
know like Disney style animation ever
you have a team of animators and the
actors on a voice-only contract and
they're sitting in a booth and they're
recording their lines and then those
animators become essentially a second a
second team of actors that figure out
what that with the performance is going
to be in the movie on the other side of
things is this is a process similar we
did on you know Planet of the Apes where
you know we would be working on set and
the director would work with the actors
and you know like Matt would lean over
to me and say like okay that was pretty
good but I think maybe we want to change
the blink or something yeah and part of
our contract was that we would go again
and when he would try to get that
performance there on set with the actors
and that became a much tighter template
that we would then match to but we would
still do what Matt's talking about which
is the editors would go in and they take
a little bit from take two and a little
bit from take five and they come back to
take two and they would refine the
performance by blending the best bits of
everything that the actor did there on
the day do you find this is for CeCe and
Karen do you find that you do more takes
or less takes from a conventional film
you know when you're in the zone when
you're doing usually it about the same
you know when you're doing performance
captures you find that is like you spend
the same amount of time on getting your
scenes or is it is it shorter or longer
and because I've heard from somebody
somebody told me they said yeah like
everything's a close-up there's no wide
shot so the actors are you know any any
tape could be used as a close-up like if
you like your previous take I'd love to
hear from you guys on that well I I can
really own the answer this for the
standpoint of what is it like to work
with Matt Reeves because I mean because
no I mean this sincerely in no way is it
any different i I didn't define it
any different filming the performance
capture role of more Reese than I do
from any other role I've done however if
you're working with Matt Reeves who is
going incisively deeper and deeper and
deeper in on every single take it's very
likely that you could wind up doing 20
takes of something as Matt got carves
closer and closer to the truth of the
scene so I would say that the number of
takes is totally dependent on the
refining of storytelling from the
director
I didn't notice and I mean there's
obviously the things that one if there's
say you know the human actor like Amaya
and the scene so there might have to be
another pass that one has to take the
human pass and everything but that aside
I didn't find that the technology
affected the number of takes at all it's
just the storytelling because it's it's
no different from my perspective as an
actor my involvement is just with the
storytelling that way we did make you
wear that horrible suit I mean this sofa
oh my god because maurice was a
character that was about I don't know
three times the size of Karen and we had
a little girl that was writing Maurice
so I couldn't anything that I touched I
whenever I touched anything and I am I
wrote on my back a lot and was
constantly connected to me so they built
what I called the sofa from the moment I
saw it it was like this thick and it was
weight about I don't know what it
weighed but I remember all the remembers
when it was brought down before we
started filming I shouted like the day
before we started filming more anyway
yeah so that that was a few technical
challenges yeah but that doesn't really
increase the that maybe the time
preparing for the shot but not the
actual number of takes yeah I have to
ask Cece did did he really have a tale
that you've you'd like a tale that you
flopped in that scene where you go as
tale like yes you're you're not wearing
much costumes yeah it was just
distinguishing who from home so I had
ears and I had a tail and I
this beautiful sort of not that
elaborate necklace that you saw me
wearing but something that definitely
said that's Mowatt and just in terms of
its individual because of who the
director is so my director is Jim
Cameron
he is a master technician he does not
act so everything he sees he he tweaks
we do a lot of rehearsal and then when
that camera is ready to roll
he's picking up several things at once
there are many cameras yesterday Cece
told me something about like this I'd
love if she could just say it again
because it was like you said it this
this technology sort of takes you back
to when you were kid and you'd say say
that well I was going to mention it for
bit you we were so pressured for time
but it's kind of like the kid who gets
the fabulous gift in a beautiful box the
gift gets chucked aside and the box
becomes your ship your airplane your
first house you know your funeral coffin
and all of these things that your mind
just roams free for in this vom which I
know is changing because I came from
mocap motion-capture you're just in a
large gray box and you're told you know
horses are chasing you rocks are flying
from the air you know roll down that
hill duck under scream there's fire
right behind you and you're seeing
nothing sometimes they're throwing
sponges at you
get out paper whatever they can't
because the scene is already set and
you're just the live instrument that
goes into it to make the entire scene
come alive again I think it's just
beautiful because it takes us back to
being kids you know what I mean back to
square one
all right we have some actual questions
from from the audience and I have one
question of my own that I want to ask
too so the first one is what as actors
can we do to prepare for the technology
in casting for the future projects and
new skills or anything like that I think
that's a great question just briefly I
think do not think of technology because
this is the one thing that they cannot
quite grasp yet is you come in with your
talent your bag of emotions and what it
is you want to portray about a character
and just show them what you have to
offer absolutely um it does as somebody
said earlier I think it's been said a
couple of times to look maybe and II set
it to what it opens up in terms of like
the end of typecasting in a way in that
way though if there's other ways that
one doesn't need to think in that in
terms of typecasting but if you can
embrace it or bring in your performance
and explore as far as you can whether
it's an orangutan or a nine-foot tall
whoever if you can go there in your
thinking and your imagination and in
your own exploration of that then
there's possibilities of these ways to
capture it so I don't think it's about
the technology at all I think it's
actually about just even going further
deeper in as an actor in setting
yourself free to that I also say that
where all this stuff is going is trying
to strip away a lot of the the
technology you know despite that a lot
of the tech that you're seeing and that
the current state of the art you know
where it's rapidly going is trying to
strip all that away to make this as
natural and friendly for the performers
as possible and we do really feel
strongly that everything that we're
doing we're trying to create the best
conditions for performance
we can and we strongly believe that you
know two characters are in a scene they
got to be playing their performances
against each other and not you know this
person's captured three months later but
you know that when they say I need a
younger version of CCH pounder it's
gonna be so much easier now but I mean
as well the the problems in the
preparation that's kind of our job to
figure out like I don't think from the
actors it's not their problem that's
that's the visual effects problem like
how do we remove all the limitations and
make it as easy as possible okay the
next question is can you elaborate more
on the animator artistry that goes into
helping and bring these performances to
life and it bears brings to mind
something I was always taught when I
start I think when I was working on t2
at ILM and somebody just came up to me
said animation is acting and and every
ball of everybody had to do a scene that
really had to animate you know the t1000
there I had a mirror and everybody
looked into the mirror and Matt was
saying they still do it we still did I
of course yeah I mean we're all actors
that don't get behind the camera we're
behind the camera in the form of you
know giant creatures and things like
that but what all the same principles we
study and things that we look at we look
at other performances and when we're
breaking down a character that's the
first thing we do no matter what it is
but if it's an animal we have tons of
references if we're out there also
shooting reference of each other we have
an animators acting room in the building
for us to go into and do whatever roll
around and you know a lot of the stuff
we have to do is pretty physical so you
know we've got certain animators that
we've actually typed casted for
different things so it is very much
performance driven and how much of that
we do like I said before varies from
project to project so sometimes it's a
hundred percent keyframe we take it over
and it's it's the animators performance
and it may be just an actor's voice
other times like I said it's very we
want to stay as true to whatever you
know needed to be done for that so you
know if it's something like more easier
you know you want to stay pretty darn
close to what that performance is so
it's less invention and more about you
know getting that performance across
that you want but yeah it's
we'll do everything in the book but the
one thing that has changed a little bit
over the years as animators kind of
trained and you know I from kind of a
disney style but that doesn't work in
this case so you kind of have to throw
the rulebook out a little bit and really
study the way things move and this is
where motion capture is fantastic for
animators because there's a lot of weird
stuff if you animated that you'd get it
rejected but you know when it's motion
capture and they do a weird foot thing
it's it just brings that extra layer of
life to it so I'm fine I think it's a
fantastic tool for bringing performance
okay another question is do you need
formal training if to do most
performance captioners so where do you
study
motion capture websites whatever right I
mean I think woody Schultz might be in
the audience at this point but but one
of the things is it seems that each
company because the genre of their film
is so special and secretive my
experience is that they teach you
everything on-site and that's probably
why it takes so long but once you've
learned something then you're actually
quite equipped whatever the next film is
coming and from that from the visual
effects side I would say work with as
many talented companies as you can work
with I was fortunate enough to work at
John's company for a while in touch with
magic I learned a great deal right and
and because you if you try to work with
talented people you'll learn how they're
addressing the current technology and
all you know all the big talent
companies NPC DNA ILM what are all just
pushing the boundaries as hard as they
can right every day Digital Domain as
well right and in terms of preparing to
do this kind of work the advice I'd give
to actors is is do your best to just
ignore it you know they don't do
anything different act as you would if
none of this technology was present
because that's what we're really
interested in and if you do try to learn
the technology and your last thing about
it is going to be different next year
anyway and then one other things here
too the sake the technology also most
the technology is really geared around
how to
help the actors in their performances
and one of the things we've been able to
do and see a lot more of is getting the
actors in for initial sessions then be
able to turn around a version of them as
their creature or their character so as
they're actually doing the performance
unset as they're doing there's like
performances they can actually see what
the character's going to look like how
much of that performance comes through
so it's no longer quite as blind as it
had been in the past
yeah good example for me recently and
that was on rogue one we had alan tudyk
playing a droid character and we invited
him up to two ILM and he spent an
afternoon in our motion capture volume
with thing we call the magic mirror
where he could see his his performance
in real-time mapped on to the droid
character so that he had a chance to
play around to see what sort of motions
looked good on the droid and how loose
does he want to be does he want to
extract some more stiff and robotic or
you want to kind of have a service
slouchy attitude and he got to spend an
afternoon trying stuff and seeing what
felt right for the character and he he
was able to internalize that and then
bring that to the set so he sort of went
into that you know with some confidence
that what he was doing was gonna look
good on the character and I remembered
my thing about about the the truth it
seems as if finding the truth in the
performances is preserving what's true
for actors in the director and then the
animators when they need to directed by
the by the director they come in and
they they try to apply the same truth so
it's it pulls true and doesn't break
character right like whatever we do we
definitely don't want it to be any
different than the character you guys
are playing because that would just blow
it horribly yeah I think the truth is is
that we probably have to wrap this up
truth is right one last one last
question is do you think performance
capture will ever be nominated in the
acting acting category gosh I hope so
so do I
well so many people do not know what it
is and didn't recognize it the first 20
times it came around well this concludes
our show tonight and remember the future
can be scary but also exciting one thing
for sure is that will always happen in
the change will always happen in the
world of entertainment but telling a
good story will never go on a style
please check out the performance capture
suit in the lobby on your way out and if
you have time to fill out a survey to
suggest what other topics you'd like to
see in these presentations please do so
I just like to thank all you guys for
doing this thank you so much well thanks
for coming thank you all for coming
tonight thank you good night
[Applause]